durante una reunión de emergencia con la
cúpula militar de su país el Primer
Ministro de israelí Benjamín netanyahu
prometió responder con contundencia el
ataque con misiles desde el Líbano
en cuanto a la agresión contra nosotros
en otros frentes golpearemos a nuestros
enemigos y pagarán el precio de
cualquier acto de agresión
unos 30 cohetes fueron lanzados desde el
Líbano contra Israel al menos cinco
impactaron en tierra hiriendo una
persona y causando daños materiales
Naciones Unidas Francia y Estados Unidos
condenaron el ataque el mayor de este
tipo desde la guerra de 34 días que
Israel libró con trajes bola en 2006
ciudad de la extrema gravedad de la
situación instamos a la moderación e
instamos a las partes a evitar una mayor
escalada
el Primer Ministro
micati rechazó cualquier operación en su
territorio que sirva para atacar la
estabilidad en Israel el ataque ocurre
un día después de que la policía Israel
irrumpiera violentamente La mezquita de
Alexa en Jerusalén el tercer lugar más
sagrado del islam con el fin de
desalojar a palestinos atrincherados que
respondieron con piedras y fuegos
artificiales
este año es la primera vez desde 1991
que la semana santa judía coincide tanto
con el mes sagrado musulmán del ramadán
como con la Pascua cristiana